how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
related to Marvel and the MCU big shout
out to everybody who stopped by my
livestream last night as I was checking
out Deadpool in fortnight I super
appreciate everybody dropping by today
we have some gambit news
gambit the movie that was lost Fox was
supposed to be doing their own solo
gambit film with Channing Tatum as
gambit himself but unfortunately due to
whatever circumstances happened
Fox put it on hold and the film died
which of course was a true bummer to
fans but we are now getting a new word
about gambit coming to the MCU so I'll
fully breakdown this report about gambit
finally coming on-screen in the MCU if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
Marvel content and I'm giving away an
Xbox one or ps4 at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so this
report comes from my friend Mikey Sutton
who was an insider in the community who
has leaked many things in the past he
posted it in his group ki Gossett II and
then he personally emailed it to me and
it reads as follows
some say the New Mutants is cursed
because it has yet to be released
anywhere but it's another x-men spin-off
gambit that didn't even face cameras to
begin with despite numerous attempts for
a launch
if a Marvel property had faced
unrequited love it would have gambits
face on it off and on when Fox still
owned the property gambit was eventually
turned down after initially being
invited to prom when Disney acquired Fox
gambit discovered we're broken hearts go
and according to Mikey Sutton he said
that a few months ago he actually
learned a few things about gambit over
at Disney and he says first Channing
Tatum is gone according to insiders
there are no plans to have Tatum play
gambit at all that ship has sailed
could it change anything is possible in
the upside down but it doesn't look like
it's in the cards right now apparently
from what mikey has heard they prefer
somebody younger a Harrison Ford type a
charmer who is a little rough around the
edges secondly there's not going to be a
gambit movie gambit will appear in the
movies but there is no solo film being
discussed right now what they do see for
gambit however is a TV series set in the
MCU on Disney plus the tone they talked
about is a modern Western a mutant
Maverick if you will with the sly wit
and gritty action enveloped by a New
Orleans
flavor Mikey says that this is extremely
early in pre development but make no
mistake gambit is coming which is
absolutely incredible news because a lot
of people including myself we're
actually pretty heartbroken when we
found out that we weren't going to be
getting the gambit movie with Channing
Tatum but gambit actually having his
very own Disney Plus Marvel studio
series makes a lot of sense of how Kevin
Feige plans on introducing and involving
the x-men and the MCU because from what
we know we know that Kevin Feige isn't
going to introduce the x-men in one big
film instead what it sounds like he's
planning on doing is introduced the
x-men gradually over time one at a time
tuna time appearing in other movies for
example Mikey Sutton has reported in the
past that rogue could be in Captain
Marvel 2 as the villain and that could
be how more x-men and mutants are
introduced as well and Mikey also
mentioned in his report that apparently
Marvel Studios and Disney are looking
for and prefers somebody that's younger
a Harrison a Ford type they said someone
charming but a little rough around the
edges which of course was Harrison Ford
during his time on Star Wars
Indiana Jones laid runner etc and this
also lines up with what Marvel Studios
wants to deal with all of the incoming
x-men as well
it's like casting a Wolverine a lot of
people want people like Keanu Reeves but
unfortunately he's just a little too old
they need somebody that's going to be
young and can tackle the character for
another 10 to 15 years the same goes for
gambit and for any other mutants an
x-men that are going to enter the MCU
the actors that are going to be playing
the main mutants and x-men in the MCU
are going to have to commit to the
character for the next 10 years at least
so having somebody that's younger and
more edgy play gambit makes a lot of
sense not that Channing Tatum is old but
he may not want to commit to the
character for another 10 to 15 years
which in the long run is what is going
to benefit Marvel Studios and the MCU
the reason the infinity saga was so good
was because we watched characters like
Iron Man Captain America Black Widow
Hawkeye Thor all developed from the very
beginning of the MCU and then come
together that's what we're going to get
from the x-men they're going to start
off as individuals and then Professor X
is going to bring them together and form
the x-men and according to Mikey even
though gambit is being eyed for a Disney
Plus series he's still going to be a
part of the movies and the MCU of course
so let me know what you think about this
report in the comments down below how
excited are you to finally see a gambit
in the MCU let me know down below and
don't forget to leave a like for gambit
and subscribe to my channel so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to them see you for live updates and
stupid memes don't forget to follow me
on Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof